[Musique]
c'est l'heure de l'invité politique
aujourd'hui c'est olivier faure le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
et député de seine-et-marne bonjour
olivier ferrand jours alors nous sommes
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté
aujourd'hui par stéphane vernet qui
dirige la rédaction parisienne de ouest
france bonjour stéphane jours et on va
commencer par évoquer à les violences
policières et l' enquête autour de la
mort de cédric joue via ce libraire
parisien qui est mort en janvier dernier
à la suite d'une interpellation d'un
contrôle de re de route routier
policiers on a appris hier et bien le
contenu de cette interpellation très
musclé cédric joue via aurait crié à
sept reprises
j'étouffe aux forces de l'ordre on a
appris également que les policiers mis
en cause avait été entendu en garde à
vue la semaine dernière et ce qu'il faut
des poursuites judiciaires forte dans
cette affaire bien sûr bien sûr on ne
devrait jamais mourir pour un simple
contrôle routier est ce que cédric joue
via présenter une menace grave pour les
policiers qui l'ont interpellé
d'après ce que l'on sait non est-ce
qu'il était armé non est-ce qu'il était
lui-même dans une forme de résistance
violente par rapport aux policiers pas
davantage et là effectivement la vidéo
qui maintenant circuler fait apparaître
le fait qu'un homme dix à sept reprises
j'étouffe et malgré tout il a continué à
étouffer il est mort donc évidemment ça
ne peut pas rester complètement ça ne
peut pas rester impuni il ya les
sanctions qu'elle s'appliquait parce que
la police républicaine elle doit
appliquer les principes républicains et
les rires la république ça n'est pas ça
qu'est-ce qu'on est assez sévère envers
les violences policières aujourd'hui en
france il ya des questions à se poser
notamment moi je souhaite l'indépendance
de l'hygiène et de l'igpn
je souhaite que nous ayons une un
contrôle qui s'effectue de manière
totalement indépendante impartiale parce
que il ya beaucoup de plaintes et il ya
peu trop damnation et ça laisse penser
qu'aujourd'hui quand la police est
à la fois juge et partie et bien l
intolérance qui ne sont pas tolérables
en république et donc il y a
effectivement un problème aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que les vidéos dont on
parle ce matin sont rendus publics où
apparaissent aussi tard est-ce qu'on est
dans un délai normal à votre avis où on
n'aurait pas plus à voir plutôt ça on
aurait pu le savoir plus tôt maintenant
je ne sais pas comment mais pourquoi il
sait pour quelle raison ça arrive si
tard mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
affligeant et qu' on ne peut pas si on
veut aujourd'hui avoir une police qui
soient respectés il faut que la justice
passe
y compris quand il s'agit de policiers
tout le monde sait que c'est un métier
difficile tout le monde sait que c'est
un métier extrêmement exigeants et tout
le monde
ils méritent notre reconnaissance pour
ceux qui le font je n'oublie pas que il
y a quelques années à peine le chanteur
renaud embrasser un flic 1 lui qui les
avait si souvent conspué par ce que il
était ce qui nous protège aussi contre
le terrorisme me contre la délinquance
contre le banditisme
c'est une évidence mais ça ne donne pas
un permis de tuer voilà et donc ça
suffit à ce qu'on se reprenne tous et
qu'on se pose la question de la doctrine
maintien de l'ordre
dire que tout là tout est affaire de
proportionnalité vous ne pouvez pas
accepter l'idée aujourd'hui que le élevé
des plus être utilisée lors d'une
manifestation qui a face à vous des gens
qui manifestent pour la plupart de
manière pacifique
est-ce que vous accepteriez que votre
enfant lycéens collégiens qui met des
poubelles devant son lycée où sont le
collège se retrouve avec un oeil éborgné
parce que tout simplement les policiers
ont jugé que c'était finalement un moyen
qui était mise à leur disposition
moi je crois que non non il faut qu' il
est à chaque fois un lien entre la
menace et les moyens qui sont utilisés
et quand je regarde ce qui se passe dans
nos pays voisins
qu'est ce que je vois je vois que la
doctrine était un ordre est totalement
différente qu'on maintient à distance
les manifestants avec par exemple des
jets d'eau qu'on fait en sorte que là ya
pas de menace létale or en france ce qui
est apparue progressivement c'est que il
y à un risque à manifester ce n'est pas
normal c'est une latte et
constitutionnel alors vous avez demandé
la création d'une commission d' enquête
sur les violences policières
hier à l'assemblée nationale où on est à
la création de cette commission
alors ça doit être fait dans les
prochaines heures
c'est une commission qu'on souhaite pas
limité d'ailleurs aux seuls policiers il
s'agit de se poser la question
pour l'ensemble de ceux qui ont un
pouvoir régalien aujourd'hui et qui
peuvent être parfois se laisser aller au
racisme à la discrimination la violence
à l'humiliation et donc et pas seulement
d'ailleurs
enfin le parti populaire s'est il s'agit
de se poser la question de savoir
comment est ce que on arrive
effectivement à ce qu'on a appelé une
république exemplaire exemplaires ça
veut dire que ceux qui regrettent l'état
ces agents doit être à tout moment mais
sa représentation et donc ils doivent
être dans une forme de rappel de ce que
sont nos règles communes et donc que ce
soit pôle emploi où que ce soit dans la
police partout on doit être indiscutable
et personne ne peut être dans la
discrimination comme ça a été parfois
révéler donc cette commission enquête va
être créé dans les prochaines heures à
l'assemblée et qui valait diriger est ce
que c'est la république en marche
puisque vous aurez un rôle de rapporteur
savait que la règle c'est que on a soit
la présidence soit le rapport je ne sais
pas encore ce que moi je préférerais
qu'on est le rapport met donc que tout
ça était déterminé avec la conférence
des présidents
vous avez évoqué l'indépendance de
l'hygiène et de vie gipn la doctrine les
outils employés
quelles sont les mesures qui pourraient
quels sont les autres mesures qui
pourraient qui pourrait améliorer les
choses
par exemple là on voit que la vidéo joue
un rôle crucial dans la sphère souvient
est ce qu'une caméra piétons par exemple
l'équipement des policiers d'une caméra
piétons ce serait une bonne mesure
absent durant cette visite était l'une
des dernières mesures prises par le
gouvernement précédent et qui n'a pas
été malheureusement suivi d'effet donc
aujourd'hui et pourquoi ça n'a pas été
suivie d'effet pourquoi ces japonnais
pas pourquoi à l'autre jour je discutais
avec une policière qui m'a montré sa
caméra je dis bah vous avez été équipé
vous elle me dit ah non pas du tout en
fait toute cette caméra c'est moi qui me
la suis acheté tout seul parce que je
préfère avoir cette caméra piétons qui
me protège aussi et qui permet de dire
que effectivement je n'ai pas été au
delà de ce que sont mes prérogatives
il faut que c'est une bonne mesure mais
heureusement c'est aujourd'hui cette
policière qui se les acheter elle même
ça veut dire que le ministre de
l'intérieur ne met pas en oeuvre les
lois précédentes voter dans les
gouvernements précédents faut croire
qu'aujourd'hui le ministre parle
beaucoup mais n'agit pas forcément
qu'est ce que vous pensez et bien du
récipissé lors des contrôles de police
et ce qu'il faut mettre en place
oui je crois que c'est une erreur de ne
pas l'avoir fait donc c'est une erreur
du gouvernement socialiste françois
hollande
oui je pense que c'est une erreur nous
n'avons pas voulu le faire parce que
nous avons jugé à cette époque c'était
peut-être trop en demander
et que les policiers dans leur majorité
étaient plutôt hostile mais ce qu'il
faut qu'ils comprennent aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est non seulement une
protection pour les gens qui sont visés
mais c'est aussi une protection pour la
police elle-même c'est l'assurance
d'avoir une police qui n'est plus jugé
comme discriminatoire mais qui est une
police points jugent tous comme
républicaine or le lien entre les
français et leur police
il est essentiel un état de droit c'est
essentiel on ne peut pas accepter l'idée
qu'il ya un divorce croissant entre une
part de la population et la police
alors parlons de l'actualité judiciaire
et de la fère fillon qui est relancé
après les propos de l'ancien procureur
national financière il ya noulette qui a
dénoncé et bien des pressions de sa
hiérarchie judiciaire si ces faits sont
avérés
ça veut dire que le gouvernement
socialiste de l'époque a essayé
d'influencer la justice
à quelles fins à quelles fins pour
éliminer françois fillon de la
présidentielle mais je ne crois que je
ne suis pas sûr que dans la dernière ils
seront présidentielle les socialistes
aient été en mesure de l'emporter et je
ne vois pas très bien pourquoi nous
aurions poussée qui que ce soit pour
essayer de détrôner un candidat de
droite
alors même que nous étions très bas dans
les sondages et que nous savions très
bien que cette présidentielle n'était
pas un n'avait pas gagné n'était pas
gagnable
mais pour essayer de qualifier un
candidat plus proche de françois
hollande comme emmanuel macron par
exemple je ne sais pas si on peut le
qualifier ainsi et à l'époque en tout
cas est par ailleurs si on veut bien en
revenir n'ont pas la spéculation mais au
fait est la réalité c est ce qu'il ya
une affaire fillon il y a une à sa fille
on est ce qu'il ya eu un emploi fictif
c'est vraisemblable et les soupçons qui
pèsent sur le travail qu'a effectué ou
pas sa femme
ils sont assez larges et partagez donc
c'est oui voila je sais bien qu'on aime
bien les affaires dans la sphère mais la
vraie affaire c'est la fin le jugement
n'a pas été rendu et le jugement n'a pas
été en deçà je suis une maison des
loisirs y est
il ya certes une affaire en cours mais
est ce qu'elle est ce que la justice qui
a pas une question de justice à deux
vitesses est ce que on est est ce que la
justice n'a pas été très rapide
précisément dans le cas fillon sait ce
que c'est ce que dit par exemple un
bruno retailleau qui était le directeur
de campagne de françois fillon à
l'époque le sénateur retailleau dit
qu'il ya une instrumentalisation de la
justice par le pouvoir dans ces affaires
croît il parle de régime de faveur
je croyais que monsieur retailleau était
jusqu'ici pour une justice rapide
il voulait que ce soit une justice
qu'ils soient là la plus voilà la plus
rapide possible parce que il dit il ya
trop de délai entre le moment où les
gens sont appréhendés le moment où ils
sont jugés là justement il est entendu
bah ouais pourquoi se plaint-il alors
olivier faur on va parler d'écologie et
de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qui a remis ses propositions au
gouvernement pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre qu est-ce que
cette convention citoyenne pour le
climat lancé par emmanuel macron est ce
que c'est une étape historique dans la
transition écologique et dans la
démocratie citoyenne
l'avenir le dira je ne sais pas et
j'aimerais je partage beaucoup de ce qui
était dit ils ont repris d'ailleurs
beaucoup de propositions que nous leur
avons que nous l'avons fait je pense par
exemple aux crimes d' écocide je pense à
la au grand plan de rénovation thermique
que nous avons porté aussi et donc il y
a dans cette danse et autres ce
collectif qui s'est rassemblée pendant
neuf mois des travaux extrêmement
intéressant et qui mérite débat est
reprise et donc j'espère ce sera un
moment historique de basculement on
parle de mesures basque derrière des
mots mesures qui permettent de changer
complètement le modèle mais là il ya des
mesures qui peuvent permettre de faire
cette bascule ci avait pas trop de
mesures on est dans un bonne étiage est
sans doute trop de mesurer et sans doute
elles ne seront pas toutes adoptées mais
c'est je pense que leur volonté de dire
voilà on a réfléchi pour un neuf mois
voilà 150 propositions maintenant aux
pouvoirs publics aux français de se
saisir de ce débat et de faire en sorte
que ça avance on peut pas continuer
comme ça alors qu'a contrario les la
convention a surpris aussi en en
décidant de ne mettre que deux points un
référendum vous en sommes vous en auriez
mis plus par exemple donc on le rappelle
le crime déco side et l'introduction de
la lutte
le réchauffement climatique dans la
constitution mais les trouver j'ai
trouvé la proposition assez maligne en
fait
expliquez-nous pourquoi parce que tout
simplement ils se sont dit quoi ils se
sont dit bon le chef de l'état et
pourrait avoir une petite idée c'est de
dire je vous mets 145 propositions en
débat et puis elle est maintenant battez
vous entre vous qui on verra bien ce qui
ressort or ce que chacun sait c'est
qu'il a des propositions qui sont faites
qui ne sont pas de propositions facile
et qu'ils demanderont en fait du courage
politique
vous pensez à quoi le rideau sur 10 km
sur autoroute par exemple je vois la
polémique qui est née depuis quelques
heures et où chacun fait assaut de
prudence et c'est donc je vois bien qu'à
un moment donné il faudra que l'on fasse
des choix et que c'est toujours on est
tous écologistes n'en ai tous
écologistes pour le voisin et dès qu'il
s'agit de dire est ce qu'on prend sa
bagnole ou pas on sait plus s'il faut de
chauffer un peu moins un peu
différemment et c'est plus non plus
enfin bref tous ces sujets là alors on
est d'accord pour que la chine fasse des
efforts les états unis fassent des
efforts que tout le monde fasse des
efforts mais est ce que chacun est prêt
à en faire c'est à sa question est donc
là il met au pied du mur le gouvernement
lui disant maintenant puisque vous avez
annoncé un acte iii on a déjà vu l'acte
2 on a vu ça ce n'est pas grand chose
donc si on veut que l'acte iii soit un
acte de courage et bien allez-y faites
mais maintenant c'est un acte iii c'est
une nouvelle étape
voilà bah écoutez je sais pas quand il
faut l'appeler mais pour l'instant on
n'a pas vu la queue de non plus donc de
toutes façons pas ou plutôt si on l'a vu
on a vu que c'était la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et la réforme des
retraites c'était tout ça sociale et
vous croyez au tournant écologique du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro mais
écoutez si on se réfère à l'acte 2 qu'il
est plus social 6e 3 ressemble à l'acte
ii dans le domaine de l'écologie on
risque d'être déçu
on va parler de social olivier faure et
de pardon de la casse sociale avec le
groupe nokia qui a annoncé la
suppression de 1200 33 postes chez
alcatel lucent en france qu'est ce que
vous proposez pour éviter cette casse
sociale inévitable mais d'abord la
première chose c'est que moi ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est qu'on ait un
gouvernement qui
callen son agenda sur un agenda qui est
purement politique et qui est celui de
la relance politique d' emmanuel macron
vous avez compris que pour l'instant le
gouvernement ne peut pas dire grand
chose parce qu'on attend qu emmanuel
macron puisse trouver une fenêtre de
communication après les municipales qui
votre est désastreux pour lui et donc on
attend de voir à quel moment il pourrait
être quelque chose et a priori ce qu'on
nous dit c'est que le plan de relance
c'est un plan qui est renvoyé au mois de
septembre
mais au mois de septembre c'est trop
tard au mois de septembre c'est déjà
enfin vous voyez bien que tous les plans
se multiplient partout et qui a besoin
de dire au monde industriel au nom des
entreprises aux françaises et aux
français quelle est la façon dont on va
les aider comment est-ce qu'on va
accompagner comment est ce qu'on va
faire pour que pareil quand est-ce qu'on
capitalise celles qui ont un problème
capital comment est ce qu'on va faire
pour celle qu'a prêts de trésorerie qu
on va faire pour celles qui ont un
problème de marché et donc ce qu'il faut
faire dans ces entreprises
ça n'est pas licencié c'est au contraire
conditionner l'aide au fait qu'on
maintienne l'emploi est alors j'entends
que le président dit il fera travailler
plus mais oui sans doute qu'il faudra
travailler plus si haut c'est le ça veut
dire que il faut travailler tous mais
individuellement est ce qu'on a
travaillé chacun plus mais c'est contre
sens l'évidence c'est que il faut que
ont travaillé chacun
mais si vous travaillez plus vous fait
des heures supplémentaires pas vous
priver quelqu'un d'autre d'un boulot
qu'il pourrait faire dans qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire
il faut réduire le temps de travail dans
les entreprises qui sont aujourd'hui en
difficulté faire en sorte que le temps
de travail réduit dont ça coûte moins
cher à l'entreprise et que le
différentiel soit pris en charge par
l'état comme on l'a fait pour le chômage
partiel et que point cette période là on
utilise deux périodes la soie pour
former les salariés sur le temps de
travail réduit à de nouveau boulot dans
leur entreprise soit parce qu'on pense
que l'entreprise n'est pas viable
un niveau d'emploi équivalent à ce qu'il
était avant la crise du colis de 19 et
dans ces cas là on essaye d'assurer avec
eux leur transition professionnelle et
faire en sorte qu'ils puissent changer
de boulot et c'est comme ça qu'on
assurera aussi par exemple la transition
énergétique et des boulots ou évidemment
on retrouvera pas l'activité d'avant
et même tant mieux mais dans ces cas là
il faut pas que les salariés sur la
variable d'ajustement il faut qu'on
puisse les accompagner les aider à
changer de job et à faire en sorte que
demain ils soient à nouveau employé
ailleurs olivier faur quelques questions
rapides sur la crise sanitaire le sénat
a voté le projet de loi de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui est une
sortie partielle de cet état d'urgence
vous vouliez sortir directement de ce
régime mais oui parce que l'état
d'urgence c'est l'état d'urgence
et quand on est plus dans l'urgence
c'est une lapalissade mais il faut
repasser au droit commun et or je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on a des confiné
l'économie complètement
en revanche on n'a pas des confiné
complètement la démocratie aujourd'hui
vous avez des urgences qui maintient des
règles très strictes
par exemple sur les manifestations alors
qu'ils ne sont même pas suivies d'effet
en réalité parce que quand les gens
veulent manifester le pouvoir est
incapable de le l'interdire mais il ya
un but politique n'a fédéré que la
parole de l'état aussi il ya un but
politique a ses règles très strictes sur
les manifestations
je ne sais pas je ne veux pas faire de
procès d'intention je dis simplement que
cette absurde et ce qui est en cause
aujourd'hui ce sont les libertés
publiques et ce qu'on voit une telle
urgence apprête à l'urgence c'est que la
tentation de ce pouvoir c'est de
transcrire dans le droit commun des
mesures qui étaient faites pour être des
mesures d'exception et donc moi je suis
en vain je suis un partisan de l'eac
droit et je suis aussi attaché à ce que
notre pays est un pays de liberté de
public et de grandes libertés qui ont
été conquises et donc je ne veux pas
qu'on revienne dessus et je vois que
mois après mois année après année on
retranche progressivement et donc ça
n'est pas notre année parce que ce que
je sois ceci dit tant qu'on n'a pas
n'est pas toujours
donc on a ni traitement ni vaccin on
pouvait comprendre qu'il ya aussi la
peur d'un retour de la maladie
bien sûr mais il ya urgence il peut se
décréter ce re décrété demain s'il ya
une reprise en cas de besoin en cas de
besoin bien sûr et je ne suis pas contre
toutes les mesures qui ont été prises au
bien au contraire pensent comme le
confinement était trop tardif et pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
bien conduite et donc il s'agit pas de
de faire le procès pour le plaisir du
gouvernement j'ai simplement qu' il
n'est pas sain dans n'importe quelle
démocratie de transférer des mesures
d'exception dans
droit commun et que finalement on vivent
avec cette accoutumance à des
restrictions sur la liberté
olivier faur on va parler des élections
municipales qui sont plutôt bien partis
pour la gauche et pour le parti
socialiste qui est en passe de conserver
ses principaux bastions paris lille
rennes et nantes
finalement depuis 2010 est votre parti
est plutôt affaibli j'avais conquérir
des villes on va parler des greens kate
on va parler des conquêtes
finalement depuis 2010 est le ps est un
peu moribond est ce qu'avec ces
municipales c'est la renaissance du
parti socialiste d'abord les grandes
idées ne meurt jamais et donc je sais
bien que depuis des mois des années
maintenant on voudrait que la gauche
socialiste moeurs et je sais bien que
chaque jour on voudrait cours et un clou
supplémentaire un cercueil que chacun
voudrait remplir mais la réalité c'est
que healy a aujourd'hui des gens sur
tous les territoires qui porte ces
valeurs et qui les portent haut et qui
ont des politiques publiques qui sont
reconnus par leurs concitoyens et c'est
souvent plébiscitée par celles et ceux
qui vivent ces villes et donc oui c'est
un moment de réaffirmation de
renaissance collective et je le disais
de conquête parce qu'il ya des villes
que nous conservons bien sûr le très
nombreuses
il ya aussi beaucoup d'endroits où
sommes nous en conquête pense à nancy
france à montpellier je pense à bourges
pour sa châtillon je pense à beaucoup de
villes à saint-ouen
voilà des villes dans lesquelles nous
allons certainement je l'espère je veux
pas vendre la peau de l'ours mais
j'espère donc gagneront dimanche
prochain et voilà on sait à mammeri
aussi et je pense évidemment à marseille
je pense aussi à toulouse
je pense aussi à lyon parce que la
réalité c'est que je ne pense pas
simplement à ce que nous pouvons
conquérir à nos seuls socialistes
mais ce que vous pourront concourir avec
les autres et ce pour quoi je me bats
depuis deux ans depuis que je suis
premier secrétaire ce n'est pas pour
simplement me poser chaque matin la
question de savoir ce qui rentre dans la
case des socialistes
non je me bats pour qu'on constitue un
bloc sociale écologique démocratique
féministe qui permette d'être une
véritable alternative aternative à
marine le pen à emmanuel macron et qui
porte une espérance nouvelle
on vient de parler de climat et la
convention climat
mais qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui peut
faire que ces idées là avant ce soit
demain porter les idées elle sera tout
seul il faut des gens pour les porter et
donc je souhaite que ce blog secret et
je souhaite qu'à l'occasion de ces
municipales eh bien on affirme ensemble
quelque chose très important qu'ils
puissent nourrir la suite parce que vous
l'avez compris je ne souhaite pas qu'on
s'arrête aux municipales vous avez fait
beaucoup d'efforts d'ailleurs dans ces
municipales pour trouver des terrains
d'entente dès le premier tour dans
certaines villes avec les verts donc on
voit bien que vous avez été aussi à la
manoeuvre dans cette stratégie qui
prépare la présidentielle par contre il
ya un certain nombre de villes ou où ça
s'est pas passé comme vous auriez
probablement voulu mais je pense par
exemple à lille strasbourg ou dijon où
il n'y a pas eu d'alliance de second
tour entre les verts et le et le lps
c'est la faute aux anciens barons
socialistes
non mais s'agit pas de dire que la faute
de ces le fait que d'abord il ya
toujours un arbre pour cacher la forêt
et donc il ya bien sûr quelques
exceptions qui existent et qui sont
liées à des sujets locaux
mais ce que je retiens c'est la
dynamique qui est créé malgré tout par
toutes ces villes où nous sommes
ensemble il ya vingt-six villes dans
lesquelles nous socialistes sont en tête
et porte les couleurs de la gauche et de
l'écologie
il ya dix wilayas lesquelles nous sommes
derrière les écologistes pour ce combat
est partout il y à l'espérance d'une
victoire et donc je trouve ce moment
passionnant parce que on voudrait
toujours tout ramener à des sondages et
allah vous avez quelque chose de clair
en fait c'est pas un tournage c'est la
réalité et c'est aux avait en fait
l'affirmation d'une volonté et j'espère
que notamment les plus jeunes viendront
voter parce que c'est aussi à lui
adresser maintenant et leur dire c'est
votre avenir maintenant qui est en cause
mais c'est vous qui vous êtes levés pour
la question vous on parle déjà son
climat et mince est géniale sur la loi
votée dimanche olivier faur vous disiez
vouloir regarder plus loin que les
élections municipales regardons
l'élection présidentielle de 2022 et ce
sondage ifop on va quand même parler
d'un sondage ou et bien au premier tour
marine le pen et macro et emmanuel
macron sont au coude à coude de loin
vends au premier tour et loin derrière
il ya jean luc mélenchon à 11% yannick
jadot à 8%
pas de trace du parti socialiste qui
peut représenter la gauche en 2022
yannick jadot ou jean luc mélenchon
d'abord vous remarqué quelque chose
c'est que c'est toujours la même
histoire
en fait on fait un sondage sur les
présidentielles alors qu'on est à
quelques jours des municipales
vous vous disiez vouloir regarder plus
loin oui non mais on veut regarder plus
loin je vais vous répondre et mon mais
quand même c'est quand même une bizarre
et non vous trouvez pas que ça quelque
chose d'étonnant à ce qu'on sorte comme
ça un sondage présidentiel comme pour
faire oublier ce qui va se passer
dimanche et qui va être un désastre
électoral pour la république en marche i
pour le président de la république et
donc il ya un écran de fumée qu'on vous
projette là au milieu et qui ne rime à
rien on son nom quoi on sont d'abord une
gauche divisée mais moi je me bats pour
que la gauche ne soit pas divisée à
l'élection présidentielle je les ai déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises mais je je
souhaite qu'il y ait un candidat unique
pour la gauche et que et pour l'écologie
et qu'on puisse se mettre d'accord sur
son identité d'abord sur un projet sur
une entité pour qu'on puisse justement
ils allaient ensemble et si on crée la
dynamique ça change tout c'est un peu
comme si vous me parlez de faire de la
cuisine de seconde mais pas électorale
la cuisine tout court
quand vous allez en fait faire enfin
quand on fait la cuisine et bien vous
avez des ingrédients si vous prenez un
ingrédient vous vous dites c'est pas
grand chose et puis c'est le mélange des
ingrédients qui fait finalement votre
recette
et bien quand on teste les ingrédients
les uns à côté des autres
ça ne donne pas grand chose quand vous
les mettez ensemble là effectivement ça
prend c'est cette dynamique là qu'il
faut créer et celle ce moment là vous
verrez c'est ce qui se passe ailleurs
dans les municipales c'est que ya pas de
république en marche il n'y a pas
d'horaires et de rassemblement national
il y a au contraire une gauche
écologique rassembler et qui gagne est
le candidat de cette gauche écologique
rassembler en 2022 ça peut être un
candidat socialiste je vous pose la
question parce que la dynamique vous
êtes en train de créer
mais les verts voulaient dominé le ps de
la tête et des épaules ans et
municipales en fait on voit que c'est
pas ce qui se passe
ils ont des bons résultats mais parti
socialiste résiste quand même très bien
est ce que ça peut changer la nature de
l'alliance pour deux
22 et remettre le ps en tête moi je ne
veux pas penser comme ça dire que si on
commence à se dire d'où tu viens
et c'est comme ça que je te juge on est
sûr de ne pas y arriver
moi c'est pas d'où tu viens c'est où tu
vas et on verra bien le moment venu
celui ou celle qui est en mesure de
l'emporter s'il ya des choses qui
s'imposeront peut être même d'elle-même
et très bien moi j'ai pas de jets pas
d'action en fait je considère que la
seule action que nous ayons à avoir
c'est d'écouter les françaises et les
français de voir ce qui se dégage est
d'accepter l'idée que pour une fois va
falloir mettre les égoïsmes pratiquants
dans notre poche et que la question
n'est pas de savoir si je fais plus que
toi ce combat là il ne m'intéresse plus
je veux pas vivre ça et je voudrais
faire souvent à jaurès et un congrès qui
lui alors ça n'interesse peut-être
personne mais qui a eu lieu en 1905
et à ce moment là il y avait cette
partie dans le mouvement ouvrier qui se
faisait concurrence
c'est cette partie là se taper tellement
dessus que aucun n'arrive jamais au
pouvoir et ce jour la 1ère à 5 justement
grâce à jaurès et bien ces gens là se
sont retrouvés merci et ils se sont
valables pendant un siècle nous avons
vécu et c'est grâce à lui que nous avons
l'état providence aujourd'hui en france
merci on verra qui sera le jour est de
lyon de la gauche au 21ème siècle merci
beaucoup merci l'effort d'avoir été
notre invité ce matin merci beaucoup
stéphane bern et d'avoir mené cette
interview